vous payez très bien sûr on va me dire
vous payez très bien ça c'est pas de la
flagornerie c'est vrai parce que je
connais un peu les chroniqueurs dans les
autres émissions vous payez très bien
c'est vrai faut le dire parce que vous
êtes fort agréable aussi un pas non plus
le savez quand on a un jeu vous dire
quand on a des choses formidables autour
de soi il faut savoir les garder les
protéger des gens non des gens plus que
des choses dont je parlais des plans oui
sophy non mais enfin bon là ok il si
d'accord mais enfin en radio la sas
important le dire ouais je suis d'accord
avec vous sur les mornes en radio et sur
les morts à m
je suis d'accord ananas et toujours la
potiche de service fait directement le
même travail qu alexandre dévoisé je
pense qu'il est payé deux fois plus que
moi voir donc je vois des jeunes et
demain avec n'est pas trop on va voir
d'accord qu elle ait pas trop de quelle
radio déjà de chérie fm rfm
la raison c'est vous vous énervez que
j'appelle la patronne du groupe nrj mais
ce serait bien en peine arrière d'où les
appels que j'appelle tout de suite alors
là les monts fait la clé sébastien ouais
c'est avec elle que j'ai ronde c'est
l'appel c'est la grosse boîte la
politique
halleguen sens qu'elle sonne à la grande
pagode ces craintes et mariam c'est qui
la grande pauvreté baudecroux et mariam
je l'appelle tout de suite oui mais vous
vous parlera à prendre j'appelle mariam
du groupe donc c'est la patronne du
groupe nrj et on va voir bella reste à
voir s'il vous connaissez je suis tombé
et tu crois tu ta mère apple sait où
c'est une grande patronne ou sms
on négocie tour nous a scié pas se voir
répond on est en train de négocier son
salaire je sais bonjour bien elle va me
rappeler plus dire c'est urgent c'est
pour un salaire est ce que nous mais
beaucoup de chefs de service femmes et
en journalisme c'est exactement autant
de femmes que d'hommes et c'est qu'il
grand patron de r d'énergie c'est pas
jean paul baudecroux ici mais j'ai
appelé jean paul baudecroux
ouais je n'ai son portable
voilà j'en paquebot de crochets sont pas
là mais bien sûr que je le connais
après tout de suite jean-paul baudecroux
je vais l'appeler bon à mon avis c'est
pas qui vous êtes mais bon voilà prêt
quand même mais sur usa les nouvelles
négocier bien c'est quoi c'est chérif
ayad matinale 6 y voit très bien quoi 6h
9h va dire c'est qu'ils 9 avec deux voix
allauch jean paul c'est cyril hanouna
mots jean paul énorme ça vas y tonton
jean paul ii en forme
oui je suis je survis super bon jean
paul je suis à l'antenne en fait je
voulais te faire un gros bisou c'est à
dire qu'on l'aimé le groupe nrj parce
que c'est un groupe formidable et toi tu
sais que je t'aime fort tu le sais voilà
merci à ces voix là et il ya sophie cost
qui est avec moi qui fais la matinale de
chérie fm et je voulais juste prévenir
que demain elle va demander une
augmentation
voilà donc je suis en train de le faire
gagner des sous à bakel
voilà bah allez voir joe cole c'est le
grand patron la salle taulier c'est le
propriétaire jean paul fontaine fort et
continu et le groupe nrj je le dis à
chaque fois même sur la télé nrj 12 je
vous le dis parce que l'énergie
voilà ils font tout seul il a cédé pour
un homme seul il faut des programmes
seuls i les produits hi-fi chronique etc
oui vous êtes formidables et continuer à
faire son effet 12ème forum
quand brad forme ou jean-paul embrasse
très forte en brasse ben voilà
[Applaudissements]